support the production of more videos by
visiting the support move section on our
website the link is in the description
below thank you and enjoy so in this
video we're going to discuss the
difference between atomic mass and
atomic weight but before we discuss
either one we have to talk about this
definition there's this thing called the
atomic mass unit abbreviate as a mu
which we actually mentioned earlier in
this series it's also called the unified
atomic mass unit or just you um
depending on who you're talking to and
it's also called the Dalton a repeated
da I see that more in biology than I do
in chemistry most of the time what I've
seen those am you anyway what is 1am you
won a mu is defined as one twelfth of
the mass of a carbon-12 atom which
happens to be equal to this mass in
grams here okay so this is an important
definition that you should keep in mind
okay okay one atomic mass unit is equal
to 1 12 the mass of a carbon-12 atom
okay so what who cares right well
provided this definition protons and
neutrons have a mass almost exactly
equal to one atomic mass unit while the
mass of an electron is about one one
thousandth of an atomic mass unit and
it's essentially negligible in
calculations okay so you'll see here
right these values are almost exactly
equal to one and they're often taken to
just be equal to one okay when
calculating the atomic mass which is why
the mass number sometimes referred to as
the atomic mass but anyway uh let's keep
this in mind when we go through and
discuss atomic mass as well as atomic
weight so what is atomic mass really
it's the mass of a specific Adam and
it's usually found using M
mass spectrometer spectrometer it's a
device used to basically take the mass
of specific atoms okay I'm not going to
get into details about it at least not
in this video so let's just say for
example we're talking about silicon 28
okay so what the machine would do is
basically it would it would take the
mass of the silicon atom so look at 28
relative to the mass of the carbon-12
atom and it'll give you what's called a
mass ratio a mass ratio okay and what's
little end up getting is 2.3 3 1 for 11
/ 1 right and that kind of makes sense
it's a value a little bit larger than
than 2 28 / 12 is a little bit more than
two all right so this number should make
sense so the atomic mass of this
specific silicon isotope otherwise known
as the isotopic mass right I so loops
isotopic mass because we're talking
about the mass of this specific isotope
of silicon right not silicon 29 or
silicon 30 or something 27 we're talk
about silicon 28 specifically what we're
gonna do oops i put mess reishi on or
ration meant to put ratio anyway what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the mass ratio that we found here take
the mass ratio and we're going to we're
going to take that if and multiply it by
the mass that we actually know the mass
of a carbon-12 atom right so the mass
ratio is 2.33 1411 right we're animal
planet out by the mass of this carbon-12
atom in atomic mass units or what would
it be well if one atomic mass unit is
defined as 1 12 the mass of a carbon-12
atom one carbon-12 atom would be 12
atomic mass units right so what we get
then is 27
point nine seven 693 atomic mass units
that is our value there and you'll
notice so this is the atomic mass of
this particular isotope of silicon right
this is the ipod Tomic mass or isotopic
mass specifically at this one okay and
notice that's pretty close to the mass
number of 28 right which is why you'll
often see the mass number to be taken to
mean the same thing as atomic mass not
quite the same thing but they tend to go
hand in hand depending on who you ask
right so if you're having questions
about but what's going on with atomic
mass which is a mass number or even
about atomic weight which we'll get to
later definitely be sure to clear that
up with your instructor with your
instructor okay now on to atomic weight
what is atomic weight atomic weight is
the average it is the average of all of
the atomic masses of the naturally
occurring isotopes of that element and
it's based on percent abundance okay
what the heck does that mean right that
was a mouthful what does any of that
what would kind of explain it with an
example here in just a second but one
thing I do want to mention is that this
atomic weight is actually what's listed
on the periodic table so it's probably
something that's pretty important or
pretty useful and it is so let's talk
about this example boron boron is an
element and it has two naturally
occurring isotopes 4 on 10 and boron 11
which can be written like this boron 10
4 on 11 and it has an atomic number of 5
ok so now boron tenon born 11 both exist
of all the boron that occurs naturally
on earth twenty percent of it twenty
percent of it is boron ten whereas
eighty percent of it is born 11 boron 10
has an atomic mass of 10
point zero one three atomic mass units
whereas 411 has 11.00 9 it's on mass
units okay those are the atomic masses
of each respective isotope okay so the
question is what is the atomic weight of
forearm well it's gonna be the average
of the atomic masses based on the
percent abundance so it's kind of with
what I've got here hidden behind hidden
here so this is what we're going to do
this might look confusing what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
atomic mass of the first isotope right
in this case we're going to do it for
boron 10 4 on 10 and we're going to take
the percent abundance of boron 10 and
multiply them and then we're going to
add it to the atomic mass of boron 11
times the abundance of 4 on 11 okay now
and that'll be it for us because of the
only two naturally occurring isotopes
but this little equation I've got here
if we had more naturally occurring
isotopes we would just include them here
right and that's why it goes from one
two and all the way up to n right just
depend being the number of of naturally
occurring isotopes if you have you would
just do this for all the naturally
occurring isotopes you have all you need
is our atomic mass as well as their
percent up like this so the atomic mass
of boron 10 is up here as 10.01 3am you
we're going to take that and multiply it
by its percent abundance which is 20 so
we're going write that as a decimal is
point 20 right we're going to add that
to the atomic mass of boron 11 which is
11.00 9am you multiplied of course by
eight percent abundance which is 80 and
when we do this we'll get for this value
will get 2.00 to 6am you and we're over
here we're going to have 8.80 72 AMU we
add those up we get 10.80 9 8am you
which since we started with what is this
5 sig figs I'll just keep this the five
sig figs at ten point eight 10 a.m. you
all right with five sig figs so that's
going to be our atomic that's going to
be the atomic weight of ouran and if
you'll notice on the periodic table
that's actually the number that's
written there write that number at ten
point eight one that's the atomic weight
so again if you if you have if you're
doing a problem that has more than just
these more than just to naturally
occurring isotopes just be sure to
include them in the calculation and
another thing again I often see atomic
mass and atomic weight being used
interchangeably to mean the same thing
so definitely talk to your instructor
about what it is they're talking about
make sure it's clear kind of what
they're talking about so I do have a
question though why or how would atomic
weight you know an average value be
useful it's super useful because it can
act as a conversion factor as a
conversion factor between the number of
atoms and mass so I've got a question
down here so how many atoms of boron are
in a 12 grand sample of boron and use
one AMU equaling this many grams ok so
if we have a 12 gram so we have a 12
grams of boron right we want to take
that and figure out how many atoms of
boron we'd have frame so we have a 12
gram sample of boron that stuff we're
going to start off our calculation 12
grams of boron we're have to get these
grams to cancel but do I have boron 10
or born 11 well I have a sample right
and this sample must have come from the
Earth's supply of boron right so it
doesn't make sense to just use one
atomic mass or the other but rather the
atomic weight because it's an average
that basically accounts for all the
boron that exists naturally so what
we're going to do here we convert this
12 grams when we cancel these grams by
using this conversion fragile provide to
us so we'll have 1.6
60 5 times 10 to the negative 24 grams
on the bottom programs of boron or and
one atomic mass unit of boron up top so
that will cancel the grams of boron
there and we got to get rid of these
atomic mass units so we're gonna have
atomic mass units of boron on the bottom
and up top here i'm going to put adams a
boron so based on this we found the
atomic weight to be 10.8 one right or a
ten point eight 10 so that's basically
the the atomic weight of one atom of
boron right so this allows us to cancel
the am use here and we end up getting
our answer and since that we started off
with two significant figures with 12
grams we're going to have an answer with
two significant figures 6.7 times 10 to
the 23rd boron atoms or atoms of boron
and that's our answer there so that's
one of the places where atomic weight is
useful so I hope that video was helpful
in kind of discussing the differences
between those two and hopefully this
part of film was a little bit of was a
little bit of help as well thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to hit with a like and
subscribe for more content also followed
with University on the different social
media links in the description below
thanks and happy study